i went through a situation
where about a week ago no a little more
than a week ago
i had a headache that had no explanation
and i was concerned that i might have
coveted
and it was plausible that i would have
contacted it though i don't know of
anybody
but anyway it revealed to me something
that i think
is a reflected in many people's
experience and b that is really
significant and um pretty scary
so i didn't think there was a high
chance i had covet i thought there might
be a five percent chance that i had
covid
but in light of that i know that if i
did have covid i would go to extreme
lengths
to protect my family from getting it you
know if it came down to it
i would uh you know if i had a trailer
i'd live in it if i had to i'd rent a
room somewhere and isolate myself
and you know i'd be very careful not to
give it to anybody who came to the door
but i would
you know order food or whatever i had to
do so i wasn't contacting
uh the world would be the right thing to
do
but what i found was a
okay you think there's a five percent
chance you have coveted you need a test
okay so i went to get the test i got put
through
a rigmarole to get the test which was
bewildering i got the stupidest medical
advice
you can imagine i was told
simultaneously that i didn't need to
worry about
kovid because i had been misled by the
press to think it was common
and then i was told if i had it there
would be no way to protect my family
from getting it too
is that the same person same person told
me that inside of three sentences of
each other
um so that was an official medical
consultation
then they didn't know what test they
were giving i said is this the pcr test
we don't know really you don't know if
it's the pcr
can you find out can you look it up do
you have the the white paper that comes
with the damn test
um well i did find out it was the paper
the pcr test
um but anyway i went i got the swab and
then i waited
and i waited and i waited for a result
right
and while i waited i was in the
situation do i assume
that i do have it in which case should i
be at a hotel
while i'm waiting for this test that
doesn't make any sense on the other hand
it doesn't make any sense not to do that
so i was caught in a middle ground that
i know is stupid which is i was wearing
a mask
in the house right all the time but i
wasn't insisting that you guys wear
masks which probably if i did have covid
would be the minimum thing necessary
right i left all the windows open so we
had air flow i spent as much time
outside as i could but the point is
the limit of what you can do if you
think there's a five percent chance
you've got it
is very different than what you should
do if you actually
do have it yeah and it was a completely
incoherent
response and i have a sense that what
other people's isn't that the word that
more than anything else describes
the the collective response to this
virus incoherent incoherent yeah
absolutely incoherent and then
ultimately
i did get my test results back they were
negative
but it doesn't mean that much why
because well but before you explain that
i mean this is super important but
um really you had none of the other
symptoms and they disappeared quickly
and so
in concert with a negative result it
seems it seems likely that that is an
accurate negative result
however yeah i mean i took my
temperature daily it never went up so i
had no other symptoms
the headache went away i never figured
out what it was about but
probably just a stray headache but the
point is okay i get my result
and then i start looking into its false
negative rate and its false negative
rate is through the roof and it varies
widely depending upon
how many days into symptoms you actually
had
the test taken because guess what its
efficacy is density dependent
right exactly and so anyway my point is
i think first of all every i just
coughed during this
little chat that is plausibly the first
cough
of a uh coveted
uh set of symptoms right but almost
certainly not
right at the point that you cough do you
take action
right so we've been handed a well you
don't want to give other people covet
thing but we have not been handed good
tools with which to know if we have it
or to
trigger the top level action that you
would want to take if you did have it
and
my guess is almost everybody is
navigating this badly almost everybody
is probably rationalizing to themselves
that i must not have it until it's way
too late
at which point um there's a less they
can you know do we know
about how much covid is responsive to
our behavior
in other words the difference between a
case that is
quick to go away in one of these cases
that gives people symptoms for
months down the road i haven't seen
those data i haven't seen them
and aren't they i mean they they would
be relatively easy to collect and
there's some that would be the most
interesting and important for those of
us who could actually make sense
of okay given that i can't trust the the
collaborations of data that we're seeing
thrown at us
i'd like to be able to make my own
assessment right yeah does does laying
low
if if you think you've got it
have a an impact on the course of the
disease
i think it almost certainly has to but i
don't think i don't think the data are
out there at least not available and the
fact that you and i are
even if they are the fact that you and i
looking at all the places that we do
look are unaware of what the advice
would be
about how to keep a case mild if such
advice exists at
all the fact that you don't have a test
that's worth a damn
and therefore you know lots of people
are uh
getting false negatives who are positive
and then acting
in presumably reckless ways as a result
of it
the whole thing is setting us up for
failure that's the point yes
we are being set up not only for
personal sometimes catastrophic medical
failure physiological failure by our
lack of information
but we are being set up for
epidemiological failure on the basis
that the data is too slow to emerge it's
too low quality
and the advice on what you're supposed
to do is anecdotal at best so
lots of the answer is lots and lots of
people are dying and as much as this
disease isn't as
deadly as we feared it is potentially
much more
destructive so every time you hear
oh it's not that serious because the
death rate
per infection is low you should ask the
question
okay but how much quality of life is
being lost by people who
recover or somewhat recover because
the uh the stuff i'm reading is
certainly very frightening on that front
yeah no absolutely and here actually if
you want to show this sack
um here's just a it's a science news
article so it's published in
you know one of the top tier science
journals in the world
but it's one of these news articles from
brain fog to heart damage coven 19's
lingering problems alarm scientists
it starts with an extended anecdote um
about
a neuroscientist who is 38 and has her
own lab at university college london
um but who having quote unquote survived
covid finds herself still with
sufficient
um both uh anatomical and physiological
symptoms in terms of joint and muscle
pain
but also um neurological symptoms
um like she is
she she says she has brain fog and
such that she cannot do the work that
she is accustomed to doing
and that this is uh now i think months
oh it says she said just three weeks
since march when her body temperature
was normal
so she's not dead therefore she doesn't
count as one of the deaths
and this is it's a terrible way of
assessing the impact of a disease right
deaths versus not deaths well this
this woman's career may be over
maybe over we also don't know she's
young she's in her 30s
right we also don't know you know as
we've discussed models of senescence and
the force that pulls you towards the
grave
we don't know how much life has been
lost the fact that you die from the
initial infection
is one thing but if you've had 15 years
knocked off your life that's not an
insignificant fact
so how many lives versus how much life
it's a different way of counting it's
both counting
but it's it's just a tiny bit more
nuance it's just a little bit more
uh categorization that is required to
imagine sort of actuarially
how you know what was your expected life
uh life expectancy
um and you know in 50 years we might be
able to know
right but it would it's it's going to be
such noisy data that we might never be
able to know but
of people who tested positive and had
cases that were serious enough to be
noted um do
they live less time than uh are expected
by
uh life expectancy tables yeah and
prediction is that they will
although again that's only counting just
actual you know
number of amount of moments lived as
opposed to quality of life
right and the quality of life thing you
know it's very hard to tell from the
reports the reports are frightening of
what people experience
yeah but um there is
you know basically people are having an
attack on the tissues across their body
which gives a huge diversity of symptoms
i'm also hearing about the recurrence of
these symptoms i have one friend who has
a pattern where he had it months ago and
he recovered
and every month it recurs
and the pattern is that the degree of
severity
decreases over time this is one person i
consider him highly reliable
in terms of the pattern he's
experiencing but the point is the
diversity is way too high
to even know how to count the damage
here yeah and that maybe just one more
thing quickly before we
we finish for this top hour um
that is part of what prompted a bunch of
scientists to
create their own vaccine so this is
published in mit technology review
which is a very highly regarded
publication
and the headline is for those listening
and not watching some scientists are
taking a diy coronavirus vaccine
and nobody knows if it's legal or if it
works
okay fair enough um it's
the you know the story goes on this is
their site here
um they are calling themselves the rapid
deployment vaccine collaborative
and there's you know it's it's it's
fascinating there's there's a bunch of
good stuff here about what they're doing
what they're trying to do what they are
not
promising but their basic point is
we don't foresee a a
valid and reliable vaccine coming
anytime
soon and given that and given how much
we're seeing
about yes pretty low death rate but
really high collateral damage rate from
this virus
we are going to prioritize uh creating a
vaccine for ourselves
and so they're doing it's it's kind of
citizen science by scientists
yeah george church is a big big name
exactly so very important person um you
know neither of us has
we just came became aware of this you
know like a half an hour or so before
the podcast so we have not
fully vetted this but i guess one
question that shows up is
um you just what do you think like
should citizen scientists
even be allowed to
with tools that they have access to
because some of them have research labs
create their own um you know taking full
responsibility
for what happens um if it doesn't go
right
their own vaccines at home and you know
my first response is yeah
well yes and no it's my response that
happens i'm reading here
what their mechanism is and basically
it's a synthetic
peptide they say these peptides are
small synthetically produced
uh portions of viral sequence
now what this means is that they are
delivering
proteins which are matches for proteins
produced
by the virus and therefore what they are
doing is they are triggering
the immune system to react to
antigens that the virus itself produces
so that when the virus shows up
your immune system recognizes ahead of
time now that strikes me as
much more likely to be safe than the
alternative
which is to produce an inactive virus
which therefore
informs the immune system by actually
diversifying in your system
and spreading antigens by a mechanism
that doesn't make you sick but does
infect cells yeah now it's likely that
or
or the third case is to kill off a virus
or inactivate it so that your immune
system just sees those particles itself
right and they say here also that you
the antigen portion that they've chosen
could be substituted by others
for example the example they give is the
recombinant stars cov2
spike rbd uh and that
um you know for me what that calls up is
okay
well uh the efficacy of this or really
any
other vaccine and they say too this
doesn't have to be for this
you know you could use this mechanism
this kind of
this framework with other antigens from
other viruses
to make vaccines for other viruses
that is likely to be highly different in
efficacy
depending on which particular antigen
you use and it's going to be difficult
to predict in advance which antigen
is most likely to produce the
appropriate response in your own body
right but let's put it this way this is
potentially
a good idea the fact that they are not
using virus decreases
presumably to zero the chances of a
recombination event
informing the virus of something it
doesn't yet know
the actual virus so peptides
probably good choice however the problem
is
you're you're playing with the
information that the immune system
uses to understand what antagonists
it is encountering and so the
possibility exists for example to
trigger an autoimmunity
by leading so you've got selection
inside the body functioning
to train the virus to be invisible to
immune systems
that means the closer it gets to self
the harder it is for the immune system
to fight
it's a go-to strategy it's part of you
know aids basically
hiv digs a hole in the immune system
which it then disappears into more or
less
that's that's what an autoimmune disease
means that it tricks your body into
thinking it's you so that your
own body doesn't go after it well no an
autoimmune disease let's say that a
virus
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry a virus mimics
your own particles
and then the immune system chases it and
it starts reacting to stuff that's ever
closer to you and then sooner or later
it's attacking
you know your own tissue like uh
cartilaginous tissue and uh
rheumatoid arthritis for example right i
misspoke yes
but but the point is if you're i'm not
saying this isn't worth it in this case
i
share the authors of that paper's
fear about the danger with covid and the
necessity to do
something but in general do we want
people messing around with informing
immune systems
you know based on these things
there's a there's a big hazard here so
the point is
we really ought to be having a proper
discussion
about the costs risks and benefits
of allowing this sort of behavior
and the problem is we can't do it in an
environment where the new york times is
telling people that subways are probably
safe and
uh you know uh the who is telling us
that masks don't work and all of this
stuff
that's clearly cooked up for reasons
that have nothing to do with our
actually being informed so anyway yup
very important problem to be solved
[Music]